- All right, "Key & Peele," man,
hey, look, I know y'all busy
and everything, man,
but you should, man,
you should really watch
these videos, dawg.
We trying to help you out,
make shit funnier, dawg.
- Trying to give you
some shit for free.
- Trying to help brothers out,
try to help brothers
get this shit going for real.
Well, the one scene
this week, man,
that we thought, you know,
we could, like, tune up
for y'all
and make it better, and whatnot,
is the scene
where the two dudes--
- The food.
- Yeah, the food scene,
where the two dudes
is having a competition
to see which one of these
motherfuckers can eat more food.
- Eating.
- So watch this, man.
- Y'all got ham hocks?
- Of course.
- Well, that's what I want.
I want a plate of ham hocks,
deep-friend, blackened,
and served on a bed
of mustard greens.
- Pig feet.
I want some pig feet
and four pounds of grits.
Oh, oh, and you know what else?
Get me a little Dixie cup
full of lard.
- You know, like, in the scene,
the dudes was ordering,
like, soul food and whatnot,
but you know what would
have made it funnier...
- Dicks.
- If y'all had been
ordering dicks.
"Let me eat
a rhinoceros dick..."
- This nigga
says rhinoceros dick.
- "With some mustard
on that bitch."
You know what I'm talking about?
- This nigga stupid.
You being stupid
right now.
You being stupid.
- Nigga, why even try?
I say give me an elephant dick.
Know what I'm saying?
Mm.
- This nigga
eating the dick.
Nigga eating the dick.
Jurassic Park,
get a bunch of dicks.
- [laughing]
He's talking about
eating some dinosaur dicks.
- Bunch of dinosaur dicks
in Jurassic Park.
- "Hey, man,
why don't you get me
a full order of dinosaur dicks?"
Nigga would be like...
- [laughing]
This nigga stupid.
Nigga stupid,
nigga stupid.
- This a big-ass dick.
Must be my dick.
[laughter]
And he eat that, right.
And then what happens,
the dick give him gas, right?
He be like, "Oh, shit,
I'm trying to eat
all this dick,"
but--bloof...bloo-ah...
- Nigga, you starting
to be stupid.
- He farts and everything,
and he shit.
- Yeah, but the shit--
the poop come out
in the shape of a dick.
- [laughing]
- The poop come out in
the shape of a dick, though,
'cause he ate--
'cause that's what he ate.
You are what you eat,
nigga.
- [laughing]
- Say it, come on,
say it, say it.
Say it, nigga.
- You are what you eat.
- Nigga, no, no,
back it up, back it up.
It come out of his--
- The shit come out
in the shape of a dick.
[laughter]
That's what y'all
should have done!
- Just need to make that shit
smarter, though,
a little bit smarter,
basically.